all right so I've got a segment that is
actually pretty short here so a lot of
times I will make a tidy list of the 27
points that I'm trying to make over the
course of a segment in this case it's
really just one pretty broad point and
we want to look at it from a few
different angles
um so before I get into it Greg a
question for you uh
Fitness oriented diet you know we're
going to really clean up the diet uh
pursuing some kind of body composition
goal like let's say maybe you know going
to you know build some muscle lose some
body fat maybe you're trying to recomp
what are the two most important values
that you're going to track and monitor
as it pertains to your diet uh probably
total calorie intake and protein intake
that is a very sensible answer so
obviously total calorie intake is going
to have a huge impact I mean it's it's
going to you know determine whether or
not you're in negative or positive
energy balance or neutral and it's
really going to have a huge impact on
how your body weight and body fat
fluctuate over the course of the diet uh
but protein is a close second because
without question we know that you need
enough protein to support your goals
whether you're trying to build new
muscle or maintain the muscle that you
have during a fat loss phase it's a very
uncontroversial to suggest that if you
intentionally restrict your protein to
very low levels that's not going to be
great for hypertrophy right so a lot of
times you know we'll interact with folks
who say you know I'd like to clean up my
diet a little bit but
I'm not really that interested in really
meticulously watching my carb intake and
my my fat intake and the ratio between
them in many cases we can just say
whatever it's fine just watch your
calories watch your protein the exact
amount of carbs and fats in most cases
not really going to matter that much uh
so we know that calories are absolutely
crucial but we know that protein is
important too
um and in the evidence-based Fitness
World
almost everybody recommends getting
around 1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram per
day of protein a lot of people
alternatively will say well go for like
one gram of protein per pound of body
weight which is 2.2 grams per kilogram
so there's this particular range that
has gotten really really really popular
and what I want to the question I want
to address in this segment here is
how important is it to specifically get
within that precise range because I
suspect while I agree that that is a
very good range and and kind of the if
you know nothing about someone you just
know that muscle is important to them
and they're into fitness how much
protein should they get that is the
range of numbers that I would start with
in a in a majority of cases but I
suspect that a lot of people really
dramatically overestimate the downsides
and the ramifications of undershooting
this target range just a little bit uh
you know we came out with macro Factor
over a year ago this is a really common
genre of question is am I eating enough
protein if I go from the moderate
setting to the low setting is am I
losing something in that process protein
intake comes up a lot and it's usually
coming from a place of concern about
what if I don't get 1.6 grams per
kilogram per day so there was a
relatively new meta-analysis uh I think
it I think it was published like an
ePrint online ahead of print a couple
months ago or a few months ago but it
was by Nunes and colleagues and it the
the title was systematic review and
meta-analysis of protein intake to
support muscle mass and function in
healthy adults so in terms of the
purpose a little quote here we the
authors performed a systematic review
meta-analysis and meta regression to
determine if increasing daily protein
ingestion contributes to gaining lean
body mass muscle strength and physical
slash functional test performance in
healthy subjects so they did a really
nice uh meta-analytic model they did a
three level random effects model which
uh properly accounts for everything that
they should have been accounting for
statistically they did a very nice job
with their analysis and they were able
to pull data from a total of 74
randomized controlled trials that fit
their inclusion criteria
um now I'm going to cut right to the
chase here
um there's a quote with the the results
here the evidence suggests that
increasing daily protein ingestion May
enhance gains in lean body mass in
studies and rolling subjects in
resistance exercise
the standardized mean difference the
effect size basically was 0.22
and uh so yeah they concluded yes adding
more protein generally a positive thing
for lean body mass I'm not going to get
into all the strength and physical
function stuff because if your protein
is making you stronger it's probably
happening via increases in muscle mass
in in this kind of framework in this
kind of research approach
um now that that sounds like okay yeah
that makes sense and then when you look
into the uh the table here if you look
at table two in the original paper and
I'll put it up on the screen here you
can see that there is to some extent a
bit of a graded effect
um so they they looked at the trials
with lifters where protein was under 1.2
grams per kilogram per day and the
effect size was negative 0.14 which so
basically indicating it wasn't
statistically significant you'd look at
that and say well why would more protein
or you know why would there be a
negative effect size of lifting with you
know protein under 1.2 you'd still
expect some relatively positive effect
but you know basically when you look at
the confidence interval we can interpret
that as basically zero-ish you know so
it's not like you know lifting on a low
protein diet is going to induce
precipitous muscle loss or anything like
that but but the effect size in terms of
lean body mass gains uh four people who
were consuming less than 1.2 grams per
kilogram per day of protein was negative
0.14 when they then looked at
participants who were ingesting between
1.2 and 1.59 which is conveniently right
below that kind of optimal range we
talked about the effect size was 0 0.17
so it was in in the positive direction
there uh just on the borderline of what
we might call a trivial effect size and
then when they bumped it up to looking
at studies where intake was at least 1.6
grams per kilogram per day then the
effect size bumped up to 0.3 so this is
assuming you know we're kind of putting
these studies into bins and of course
all these studies are going to vary
across a a variety of different domains
and characteristics but broadly speaking
you could look at it and say okay that
tells us that we definitely want to have
plenty of protein and when we bump up
into the higher categories we see better
outcomes for lean body mass but there
was a quote in the uh I think in the
discussion section that I think really
highlights the point that I'm getting at
here so
they said uh they're looking at that
standardized mean difference basically
higher protein versus lower Point lower
protein the effect size was 0.22 and
they said the change represents
approximately 1.3 to 1.4 Kilograms of
lean mass gain during the intervention
compared to an average of about 0.8
kilogram gain in the placebo or control
group so what they were looking at here
just broadly speaking comparing higher
versus lower protein intakes was a
difference of about 0.5 to 0.7 kilograms
in terms of lean body mass accretion uh
so so they were kind of saying like
listen yeah this analysis indicates that
higher protein is broadly better for for
uh the accretion of lean body mass but
we're not talking about an enormous
effect here we're not talking about
several additional kilograms of lean
body mass Within These studies we're
talking about more like a half a
kilogram and then when you look look at
there's a big uh figure that I'm going
to put on the screen here when you start
to look at
the the actual effect sizes in this
Forest plot
you kind of get a better sense of the
data where for for a lot of these
studies the effect size is very
comfortably straddling the line of zero
you know when you look at the at the
confidence intervals a lot of these uh
individual effect sizes are
zero-ish or very near zero so I think
it's important to look at these effect
sizes effect sizes and really kind of
chew on them and look at them and
interpret them visually so that you can
see like when we talk about how critical
high protein is what are we really
talking about here in more tangible
terms like not just is there an effect
but what is the size of the effect and
how consistent is that effect uh and so
I think that figure shows it pretty
nicely if we go on there's a I dug into
the supplementary file and found figure
12 here which is on the screen now it's
a bubble plot and it's basically just
showing on the x-axis uh you know what
is the protein ingestion in grams per
kilogram per day and then the y-axis is
just indicating the amount of increase
in lean body mass that was observed and
you look at it and you can definitely
say okay that looks like a line that's
pointing upward right but you also see
see like you know if I'm looking at
people who are at three grams per
kilogram per day
I'm looking at a spread that on the
y-axis ranges from a value of one to you
know maybe like negative 0.25 something
like that yeah and if I look all the way
down at like
1.2 grams per kilogram of protein uh I'm
seeing a spread from like negative 0.5
up to like 1.7 now there is one that is
a bit of an outlier in that regard
that's the the 1.7 value is really
separated from the pack
um and I will acknowledge this is very
much a visual uh segment that I'm doing
here so uh if you're listening Along on
a purely audio platform might not be a
bad idea to check out the YouTube for a
little more context but I am going to
try to you know verbally describe what
we're seeing here but if you exclude a
couple very very high values
um that are kind of just I I don't I
don't use the term outlier because
there's some statistical connotations
that I haven't rigorously checked here
but but there are a couple values that
are really far away from the pack and if
you exclude those this looks like a
relatively
flat relationship once we're getting
above like 1.3 ish something like that
uh so with that in mind I wanted to take
I wanted to take it back to the original
uh so everyone always talks about this
um this range of 1.6 to 2.2 grams per
kilogram per day
and that range specifically uh to the
best of my knowledge comes from a 2018
meta-analysis by Morton and colleagues
um so they publish this work it's an
excellent meta-analysis and meta
regression project by Morton and
colleagues so I don't want it to seem as
if I'm being critical of this work I'm
rather highlighting this work and saying
let's dig in and kind of get some Nuance
from it here so uh Greg uh what we're
looking at here
um
is a figure from that study uh and it is
the figure that you see on just about
every uh evidence-based article about
protein intake uh and if you're watching
Along on YouTube you can see the figure
on the screen what I did here was I I
used web plot did web plot digitizer
which is a great tool for for kind of
extracting values from figures and
studies and I plotted it myself because
I wanted to get rid of the lines this is
a conversation you and I have had many a
time over the years when you throw a
best fit line on a regression model it
poisons your mind like you get so
fixated on the regression line like I
could take uh just a random plot of
totally just a plot with no relationship
at all if I just throw a regression line
in there you're gonna be like oh yeah I
see that Trend that makes sense yeah
um so I took all the the lines out and
stuff like that not that they're
misleading they're they're a good choice
for the original paper but
if we just look at this distribution
broadly
how would you describe it Greg
oh man
um
yeah I mean it just just eyeballing it
it looks like there is maybe a very
slight positive Association here but
um
I don't know it doesn't look like
there's any like super super clear
discernible pattern like there are
definitely fewer low values in the
vicinity of 1.0 than there are in the
vicinity of 1.75 for example but
um yeah I mean it it doesn't look like
it's not a super super clean uh super
super strong relationship uh but I would
say yeah and I mean
not to cherry pick but I'll go ahead and
cherry pick uh but you know you look at
this
um
at this distribution and you say well if
I was consuming
uh
1.3 grams per kilogram per day how
certain am I that my gains will be
materially different from someone who's
consuming 2.1
and with it if you start bidding it up
into little little uh little sections
like that you start to say man it's it's
actually kind of hard to to look at a
particular intake and say oh I'm quite
confident that you're going to be far
worse off uh at 1.5 compared to 2.25
um but anyway I'm going to show on the
screen here uh it's contextualized a
little bit more by adding some access
labels just so that we can kind of get
our bearings uh and kind of really fully
contextualize what we're what we're
looking at not just with values but but
with uh with access labels uh and then
of course I'm going to show on the
screen a linear trend line so this
linear trend line does indicate that
there is broadly speaking a positive
trajectory to this data uh the trend the
r squared value for the linear trend
line is 0.126 so what that tells us is
protein intake in grams per kilogram per
day is explaining about 12 or 13 percent
of the variance in uh gains in fat-free
Mass uh now one thing I should
acknowledge is that the authors used a
breakpoint analysis in the original
paper which means they would suggest
that a linear trend is not the
appropriate trend line for this
um but if we we look at a recreation of
the original figure
um this was actually taken from a
stronger by science article uh but but
when you add in the uh the non-linear
trend line with a break point in it you
start to see where that 1.6 number comes
from right so the the uh in the original
paper they did this breakpoint analysis
and they said statistically speaking our
best estimate of the break point here
is 1.6 and the reason they're looking
for a break point is they're saying how
high do I have to get my protein to to
get to a spot where I can say this is
Comfortably enough to effectively
maximize my gains here yeah what they're
looking at is where does this
relationship between protein and gains
and fat free Mass essentially become
flat so that's what you're seeing on the
screen but the confidence interval for
that break point essentially spans the
entirety of the data uh so so the
statistical interpretation of this would
be the break point is at 1.6 but the 95
percent confidence interval ranges from
I forget the exact numbers but it was
basically like from one to like 2.2 ish
or something like that yeah yeah
um
now this was a really fantastic piece of
research and I like I said I don't want
to make it seem like I'm being critical
but what I want to encourage people to
do is look at these data slightly
differently okay because everyone sees
this figure and when you draw the the
trend line with the break point you say
oh yeah yeah that makes sense give me
1.6 at least
um but what I want to do is kind of
reframe what we're looking at here so um
in the previous uh systematic review I
was talking about the meta-analysis by
Nunes the newer one uh I mentioned that
they had kind of broken it into
categories and one of their categories
was they're like well let's look at
intakes above 1.2 that was kind of a a
threshold that they identified now if we
look at the same data and Greg you can
follow along here we're looking at this
data and we're cutting off everything
below 1.2
that starts to really change the nature
of this relationship to my eye yeah I I
don't know if you would agree with that
I think it still looks like there's a
positive relationship there but it does
not look to be quite as as a substantial
upward Trend I would definitely agree
with that and now on the screen we're
going to look at adding in a trend line
and we're just going with a linear trend
line here uh and I would actually I
would contend that the linear trend line
is a fairly appropriate fit for this
data uh from my perspective no yeah I I
agree so when we look at that linear
trend line and we cut out the the
intakes below 1.2 and that's that's not
like arbitrary again I'm trying to kind
of pull that number from the Nunes
review we see that the r squared value
becomes
0.044 and so what that's telling us is
once we're looking at intakes above 1.2
grams per kilogram per day
protein intake is only explaining about
four percent maybe five percent of the
variance in changes in fat-free mass in
these studies
uh and there is one value in this uh in
this particular data set that is kind of
it's certainly not an outlier but it is
Head and Shoulders Above the Rest you
know there's this one value up there
that's hanging out well above three on
the y-axis that does seem to kind of
nudge us towards saying oh yeah it looks
like there's really something to these
extra high protein intakes so what I did
here is uh I essentially just removed
that one value
um which I now we're getting into the
realm of cherry picking a bit well
haters might call it cherry picking but
someone else might call it a uh a leave
one out analysis exactly and that is a
good point is that it's a very selective
leave one out analysis but a lot of
times when when someone is saying okay
you're doing a meta-analysis a meta
regression are you sure that one fluky
study isn't really driving the effect
here and what you'll do is to leave one
out analysis where you'll go through and
recalculate the whole analysis just
taking out one study at a time so you
take one study out you leave the rest
recalculate the whole meta and say okay
let's try it by pulling out a different
study so the original one goes back in
you take a new one out and you
recalculate again if that sounds awful
and tedious and unbearable
by the grace of God we have software and
so that whole process is one line of
code yeah so Props to people who make
software but but yeah and so to be clear
ultimately what you're trying to do with
a with a leave one out analysis is you
want to make sure that one particularly
influential data point isn't just
driving your results or having an undue
amount of weight so uh you know if
you're calculating an effect size or a
beta coefficient you know do you do you
see like a 20 shift in your beta
coefficient and your your p-value go
from like 0.04 to 0.15 if you leave one
study I like do you see and this is I
think oftentimes it's somewhat
subjective like basically you're just
looking to see are are there any studies
that are really really influencing this
this pooled effect we're we're observing
yeah it is subjective but you know
you're gonna if you're gonna leave one
out analysis and there's just one
particular study and all of a sudden
you're you're pooled effect size you
know drops by 30 you're like oh crap
like something is really happening here
you know and I'll note just as as is a
bit of inside baseball
I've noticed that leave one out analyzes
aren't done super frequently in
meta-analyzes and it seems like they're
almost always done when the researchers
just like do their literature search
extract the data plot it and they're
like ah [ __ ] like we've I I know what
I'm seeing here I know one of these
studies is skewing my results so let's
say we plan to do it leave one out
analysis and then we can present the
results with and without that one study
yeah yeah it's uh
it's a convenient way to say like how
can I say that that one researcher is
completely full of [ __ ] but but make it
a systematic process yeah essentially or
or at least get me off the hook for
pretending that that one particular
finding is actually like representative
and and should be included yeah yeah uh
but anyway so if we if we remove that
one it doesn't really change that much
honestly I I did it because I expected
that I would look at the data and say
whoa things are fundamentally quite
different here it doesn't really change
that much and you know it's on the
screen you can kind of make your own
assessment there it still looks like
there's generally speaking an upward
trajectory but in the interest of being
transparent if I thought it was going to
be Nifty I included it even though it's
it doesn't really fundamentally change
things that much
um I don't want to just like only
include things that are that I expect to
be interesting that end up looking
interesting yeah um so then when we look
at the trend line
again you know we do see that the r
squared value drops from 0.044 uh to
0.029 that's inconsequential uh
effectively no impact there
um and now I'm full-blown cherry picking
um but cherry picking to prove a point
so I mentioned to be fair I think that's
why most people cherry pick correct yeah
yeah so I'm yeah I'm I'm not hiding the
uh method by which I am selecting fruit
I am cherry picking here but it's merely
to be an illustration which is
but I do think it's pertinent here when
we're saying we're going to use this
body of literature to determine the
minimum uh protein intake that we should
be not just shooting for but stressing
over yeah yeah so like if you are going
to say here is the data set we're using
to make that determination I think you
should be able to stress test it and
provide various different cutoffs and
say well how how did the data look when
we frame it this way yeah I if I I think
that's an important consideration like
what what you're doing here I don't
think either of us would argue is like
the best and generalizably most rigorous
way to approach this but since there is
the question of of of magnitude and
impact like if if this is the type of
thing that is worth stressing about
that's really really worth getting in
your head about it should be I would
think robust to you know constraining
the x-axis to an arbitrary degree and
excluding one study you know yeah if
like those are those are definitely Two
Cherry picky type things to do but
ultimately that's not
that's not any sort of like extreme data
torturing and if if the relation if the
previously observed relationship falls
apart with that level of stress testing
that doesn't mean that the previously
observed relationship doesn't exist and
isn't maybe worth paying attention to
but it probably does mean that it's not
a uh a generalizably strong enough thing
that you need to lose sleep over it yeah
and and to be to be very clear I think
the exclusion of one data point is a
much more uh questionable practice than
just saying okay if you're telling me it
I that being below 1.6 is deleterious I
should be able to cut this x-axis at 1.3
and still see it yeah right because the
I'm still including the cut Point here
correct so I think that the x-axis
modifications are fair game the
exclusion of one study questionable but
as I've shown I'm just reporting like
what I was poking around at and it
frankly didn't matter so excluding that
one study is the more questionable
practice and it's the least impactful
practice of what we're looking at here
yeah so cherry picking I'm just saying
hey let's cut the x-axis at 1.24 and
just see if we really still believe that
that 1.6 cut off is a very clear sharp
delineation between sub-optimal and
optimal protein intake and when we look
at the figure including that one study
that's a little larger than the others
it's just not looking like there's much
going on here at all
um it's it's really difficult to say
that people between 1.25 and 1.75 are
worse off than people at 2.0 and above
uh it it it looks like a lot of what's
going into that upward trajectory that
we see in the original data set is the
stuff occurring below
1.24 grams per kilogram per day if we
throw a linear trend line in there we
get an r squared value of 0.011 so we're
explaining one percent of the variance
in the change in fat-free Mass if we
remove that uh that one additional data
point that's a little bit larger than
the rest uh it doesn't really
fundamentally change the visual
inspection that much but when you know
when we throw on the uh the trend line
again it just doesn't change that much
we've dropped from 0.01 ish to 0.003
um now what is the point of this whole
practice it's to say we ought to uh
stress test that range a little bit and
ask ourselves not just what is the best
cut off we can choose because I you know
while it's not
um it's not a standard statistical
practice to say let's find the break
point forget the lower half of the
confidence interval and only look at the
upper half I I have not seen that as a
commonplace statistical method
um
but I I actually I I mean I think it's a
justifiable way to view it um in in
practical in a practical sense so I'm
not faulting the researchers for doing
that but it is worth kind of just
putting that out there
um but but if if the claim is
1.6 you got to get there and if not
you're going to regret it then we should
be able to cut the axis off at 1.24 and
say do we still feel that way uh and
when we look at this data I think it
largely conforms kind of to something
that we talked about a long time ago on
the show without any data in front of us
without any kind of evidence you know
without a direct piece of evidence we
were going by we were talking about like
what is the lowest protein intake that
you feel generally like fine about yeah
and we didn't say the RDA of 0.8 we were
both in agreement that that was pretty
low uh the number that we both felt
pretty good about was like Hey get above
like 1.2 ish
um looking at this data would not
strictly uh you know uh reinforce that
number it would say
1.25 ish might be where you want to get
above if we're going to you know assume
that this data is uh you know the best
possible data that we can pull together
to answer this and I I think that it is
a very nice representative data set for
that yeah so what I'm getting at here I
think it's important to clarify what I
am concluding but more importantly what
I'm not concluding so I am not saying
that protein is unimportant nothing in
this presentation would or in this
segment would indicate that I am not
saying that protein is unrelated to
gains in fat-free Mass it clearly is uh
I'm not saying that 1.6 to 2.2 grams per
kilogram is an ineffective optimal
protein Target I actually still very
much believe that that is a very nice if
you were to ask me with no additional
knowledge about the situation someone's
trying to build muscle how much protein
and if I if you tell me to scale it by
total body mass I'm going to say 1.6 to
2.2 uh
I'm not saying that that is a bad Target
but what I am concluding
is a few very important points first of
all resistance training drives muscle
growth but the protein we're adding in
there is merely permissive and we
shouldn't lose sight of that there's a
lot of folks who worry way too much
about their exact protein intake and not
enough about am I doing the things
required to stimulate muscle growth the
the training component is really driving
the ship here uh the protein is Simply
Having a permissive effect so all we're
trying to do is get the protein high
enough to really let those gains
materialize and manifest uh what I am
concluding is protein restriction to
very low levels is definitely bad for
your gains but clearly at really high
levels of protein it becomes a bit
redundant and even the original meta by
by Morton would reinforce that point
with the flat relationship above 1.6
um but the main point I want to make
here is that there is a massive uh
I would say overestimation of the cost
of setting your protein Target at 1.4
1.5 grams per kilogram per day when we
compare it to that optimal range of 1.6
to 2.2 there's a really pervasive
misconception that the low end of that
optimal range has been determined with a
high level of precision and that there
is a very clear uh downturn in your
progress if you fall just a little bit
short of that yeah when we look at this
data and say
what what if you get 1.3 1.4 1.5 the
data would indicate that the difference
between
getting pretty damn sufficient protein
intake in that 1.3 1.4 1.5 range the
difference between pretty damn
sufficient and fully optimal is very
very slim and the lines separating those
two categories is actually pretty hard
to draw when you just put the data out
there and say where are we seeing the
dramatic drop off in gains as protein
gets lower and lower and lower so what I
would encourage people to do is be just
a little bit less uh dogmatic about the
idea that every human being should have
that lifts should have their protein
between 1.6 and 2.2
um you know I if you were to go out into
like a message board or a forum if those
still exist I don't know you were to go
into a subreddit and say hey I just
hired a new fitness coach I'm trying to
put put on some muscle they gave me this
diet uh recommendation and the protein
targets 1.5 grams per kilogram per Dairy
for this example 1.4 you're going to get
about two-thirds of that group who says
you got to fire this person right away
yeah they're a [ __ ] fraud they're
fully incompetent and the other
one-third is going to say they should be
in jail yeah uh like the visceral
reactions well and and you might have uh
one angry very radicalized vegan who
says like no abs abs that's way too high
like your kidneys are [ __ ] yeah and
before we get angry messages I actually
am vegan now I haven't told you that yet
but uh congrats I I have made the
transition The Only Exception is that I
am still I haven't been eating eggs much
because I don't feel like it yeah I'm
still very comfortable eating the eggs
from my local animal rescue because
those chickens live a better life than I
do and the reason I went vegan is just
for Animal Welfare concerns so like
those those chickens are doing just fine
um and to be clear that was that was a
comment about a a particular I think
relatively small subsection of vegans
not not vegans generally yeah but but
small subsections tend to be very
outspoken yes and that that's definitely
the case
um but anyway yeah like there has been
this um this widespread uh
adoption of that optimal range without a
lot of nuance behind it
um and it has led to a lot of mission
misinterpretations like the example I
just described which of course was
hyperbolic but I think isn't necessarily
unrepresentative
um and so with that in mind I do want to
talk uh I I want to remind people uh
that if if you're getting your protein
like 1.3 to 1.5 grams per kilogram per
day and bumping it up to 1.6 is
challenging it's infeasible it's
inconvenient or it's simply just
unpleasant for you it based on the
research does not make a lot of sense to
totally beat yourself up about that I
think people are are really disconnected
from the actual magnitude of what they
might be theoretically missing out on
there and I think there are a lot of uh
specific scenarios where I would look at
someone's diet look at their lifestyle
look at the sacrifices it would take to
get them from 1.3 to 1.6 or 1.8 I would
say honestly the the juice there is not
worth the squeeze
um it doesn't make a lot of sense for us
to be losing sleep over this and in fact
the Sleep we're losing over this is
probably more impactful than the protein
that we're missing yeah yeah
um so with that in mind I do want to
wrap this up with some kind of practical
ranges that people can lean on here and
I want to frame them based on total body
mass but also based on fat free Mass
because
um
one point of confusion that comes up a
lot from that kind of standard optimal
range is you'll find people who maybe
their goal is to lose 120 pounds right
and they're saying I read on the
internet I need to eat at least 1.6
grams per kilogram per day but my my
protein intake is astronomically High
yeah
um and the the fact of the matter is you
know when we scale by total body mass
alone there are certain ranges of the
body composition Spectrum where this
recommendation starts to really fall
flat
um and scaling to fat free mass is not a
perfect solution but it is an upgrade in
certain scenarios yeah so the category
that I consider pretty damn good for
protein intake the RDA is 0.8 grams per
kilogram per day in in the United States
I think that pretty damn good is 1.2 to
1.6 uh that is a protein intake where I
might say you know what it's possible
that we are not fully fully fully
optimizing your gains but we are getting
the Lion's Share of gains that are
currently accessible to you and what
gains are accessible to you that's going
to be determined by your genetics your
response to training and the nuts and
bolts of your current training program
uh now for the fat free Mass equivalent
uh I would say that that would be
roughly 1.5 to 2 Grand 1.5 to 2 grams
per kilogram of fat-free mass now the
optimal range I still agree I I
absolutely concur if you said my goal is
to leave no gains on the table and I I
want to leave no doubt I want to be
certain that I am in the optimal range
and I'm not under eating my protein I
still think the optimal range going by
total body mass is 1.6 to 2.2 grams per
kilogram per day and if we scale that to
fat free Mass I'd say that's more in the
range of like 2 to 2.75
grams of protein per kilogram of fat
free mass and one additional note since
you brought up vegans this was actually
already in the outline if you are
totally vegan so no eggs no Dairy no
meat no fish all that stuff and you're
very adamant about supporting fat free
mass accretion or retaining it during a
cut I do think you know we've talked
about previously uh on the show there's
research indicating if you're getting
1.6 grams per kilogram per day or above
um per kilogram of total body mass if
you're getting into that standard
optimal range vegan diets versus
omnivorous diets seem to have similar
effects on hypertrophy even as a vegan I
can acknowledge as total protein intake
starts getting lower and lower the
differences between a vegan diet and an
omnivorous diet and how they support
hypertrophy the differences become more
apparent yeah and so what that means is
it's it's very nice as a vegan to say
whatever just eat enough protein and
you're good get over 1.6 and you're fine
if you are going to give yourself a
little bit of slack and say I don't need
to push to 1.6 I realize based on the
literature I'm not necessarily losing
that much if I settle a little lower
than that I would still say like either
try to get like at least 1.4 ish if
you're totally vegan or just be really
really adamant about making sure that
you have some really high-ish quality
vegan proteins in your diet so make sure
you've got plenty of you know soy based
proteins
mycoprotein-based proteins maybe you
spend a little more time making sure
that you have complementary protein
sources you just want to have a kind of
a heightened sense of awareness if
you're on a totally vegan diet and you
are falling below that 1.6 threshold if
you're on a uh over lacto vegetarian
diet and you're still getting whey in
Greek yogurt and eggs and all that stuff
you're essentially
you're basically an omnivore when it
comes to to protein quality you know so
uh that little caveat there I'd say only
applies to pretty strict vegans
all right so I think that does it uh
like I said though basically just trying
to make one point and that is I'm not
disputing the kind of standard optimal
range for protein intake but I do think
people should uh when they really hate
getting up into that that higher range
of protein intake it's worth
readdressing the question of how much do
I lose when I settle at 1.4 instead of
1.6 and the answer based on the
literature is simply not that much
absolutely I and I think that that's a
good a good just kind of like
generalizable thing to keep in mind like
if
um
if someone is saying that something is
is good for you and you should do it and
it's going to improve your gains
um
it is worth asking
to what extent does this seem to be
generalizably true or you know is it
just like yeah one or two studies kind
of supporting this thing and uh like
what what is the effect magnitude like
if if something does seem to be net
beneficial but you know it doesn't like
the actual magnitude of the effect seems
to be quite small then it's just a
question of of how much is that worth it
to you like I think this comes up in
discussions of supplements pretty
frequently like you know the uh like
creatine in particular seems to be quite
good and then once you go down from
there you know there's there's a variety
of things that might have a beneficial
effect on on strength endurance or any
number of like acute training variables
um generally the impact isn't all that
large and so if if someone approached
all of those things with kind of the
same mindset that it seems a lot of
people approach protein with of damn
like I definitely have to get one get to
1.6 grams per kilo or I'm leaving a lot
on the table
I don't think most people apply that
same sort of thought to supplements
where it's like well I mean it seems
like it seems like citrulline malate has
a small effect so like I definitely need
to take that before every workout beta
alanine that's hard to say may have a
small effect definitely need to take
that before every workout like if if
that is the sort of uh uh reasoning
process you go through you you're going
to wind up being on the hook for doing
all sorts of [ __ ] that may be beneficial
but probably only has a relatively small
benefit
um so yeah if you don't go down that
road for any number of other topics
probably not worth going down that road
and getting like that obsessive when it
comes to protein
um and if you do find yourself going
down that road on a lot of different
topics pretty frequently I I would just
uh implore you to take a step back and
ask yourself
how much is this actually going to
affect me and is is the cost worth the
anticipated benefit yeah and you know I
will say it's one thing I remember when
I was younger and you know especially
with supplements I intuitively
understood that the effects would be
small but I had fun yeah and I wasn't
doing anything dangerous you know I was
I wasn't taking any you know dubious you
know well I you potentially were
the supplement industry back then well
had a pretty big issue with uh heavy
metal contamination that we didn't find
out about until after the fact that's
true um
yeah but you know I was I was selecting
you weren't knowingly doing anything
that was risky I was selecting products
that if manufactured correctly had low
risk profiles right so yes it was there
was minimal skin in the game it was oh
I'm gonna have some fun and see if beta
alanine does something for me you know
the cost was not super cheap for a
college student but cheap enough to
swing it you know so there's two
different ways that people approach this
like are you sweating over all the small
details because you're very worried and
concerned
or are you exploring the small details
because you're curious and inquisitive
and you enjoy that exploration process I
view those as two very very different
things and so I try not to stifle people
who want to try to mess around with some
of the smaller stuff and kind of say oh
wow that was nice I think I'm getting
something out of it
um you know versus like yeah if you are
just in a constant state of dread
because you think you need to increase
your protein intake by 0.3 grams per
kilogram per day
you really got to revisit that yeah yeah